get 12 weeks of the spectator in print
and online for just 12 pounds and we'll
give you a 20 pound
amazon gift voucher absolutely free
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash
voucher
hello and welcome to the spectators book
club podcast i'm sam leath the literary
editor of the spectator
and this week i'm very pleased to be
joined by the former australian prime
minister
julia gillard whose new book co-authored
with the nigerian former finance
minister and
foreign minister and economist ngozi
akonjo iwa i hope i
pronounced her correctly is women and
leadership
real lives real lessons julia welcome
thank you very much great to be with you
can you tell me how this book came about
i mean how did you
and and cozy get talking and what made
what made us think we'd do this crazy
thing and write a book
we first met each other back in 2012
when i was prime minister and ngozi came
as part of the
nigerian delegation to australia for the
commonwealth heads of government meeting
but really we got to know each other in
international meetings in my time
post-politics i chair the global
partnership for education
she chairs the global vaccine alliance
so we ended up at any number of
conferences and events together
and we got friendly we got talking and
increasingly
we started talking about what was
happening to women leaders around the
world
and we'd be you know watching and seeing
sexist treatment and we're trying to
work out how systematic is this is
every woman's experience a bit different
or are there common themes
and then when hillary lost we finally
said to each other we've got to do
something about this and so that was the
birth of the idea of writing the book
i mean you say hillary losing was this
kind of
crystallizing moment was that because
you think
you know things are going backwards in
some ways yes i mean
i'm enough of an optimist to say that
the
general direction of travel is forward
and
even in the days after hillary lost
whilst i was quite saddened indeed very
saddened
i would have said rationally no the
direction of travel is forward
but it was shocking enough for us to say
this does require more energy more focus
the world might slowly slowly slowly be
getting to a better place
but we really want to quicken the pace
of change hence the book
and in the book you're it's not just a
treatise it's a reported book
you know you've two of the best
connected women in the world
and you've drawn on those connections
how do you go about it because you
interview
eight very eminent women you know
leaders
world leader level women you know what
made you choose them and
how did you go about it what did you ask
them well i would hope ngozi and i
brought to this
lived experience and we share some of
that
what in the old days we would have
called pretty good rolodexes
we know women around the world and we
were able to get eight very eminent
women to share their real life
experience with us
and hopefully we've also brought a bit
of a policy analysts or researchers
eye because we've aggregated together
the global research about women and
leadership and so the
main aim of the book is to take that
research and to see
does it live in real life do women as
they go about their leadership
feel the same things that the
researchers suggest they should feel
in terms of selecting the eight women we
wanted the book
to speak more broadly than politics and
so we originally thought should we get
women from the business community women
from civil society women from the law
and so on but we ultimately decided that
the spotlight is at its
widest hottest on women in politics
and so any lesson that could be learned
from women
in politics would be likely to resonate
with women in other circumstances and
the lessons would be
the sharpest and starkest from their
experiences
but it's also i mean that they're not
all as it were
western women i mean you've you've
chosen you say at one point you chose
scientifically almost you wanted to show
a arranged in you
so who've you got and who do you wish
you had i know your cross at missing out
on angela merkel
we would have loved to have spoken to
chancellor merkel unfortunately that
wasn't
possible but i do hope that she writes
on gender
but we did decide that we wanted women
from
around the world we wanted this to be a
truly global book
obviously ngozi and i are different
women me
from australian politics her from
nigeria
and we wanted to select women with
diverse experiences so to do the
round-up
from your region of the world we spoke
to former prime minister theresa may we
spoke to the current prime minister of
norway erna solberg
we spoke to christine lagarde obviously
she was in french politics then went on
to the imf
the international monetary fund and now
with the european central bank
we couldn't miss out on hillary clinton
given how
resonant her experiences are we spoke to
michelle bachelet
who was twice the president of chile
we spoke to ellen johnson surly the
first woman to lead a nation in africa
from liberia we spoke to joyce bander
the second woman to lead a nation in
africa she was president of malawi
and from my region of the world we spoke
to jacinta
ardern so women from very different
walks of life
very different countries and contexts
well what then do the women who achieve
that sort of eminence have in common
did you find and what surprised you well
actually i was surprised how much was in
common
i mean when you look at these women's
experiences
you know on the first look you would say
well
nothing is in common you know ellen
johnson sirleaf who survived
imprisonment exile death threats
to end up leading a civil war
torn country to end up leading liberia
what could she have in common with
ernest solberg
who is the second woman to lead norway
and obviously norway is one of the
richest countries in the world
and yet when we took another look
actually
ernest solberg and ellen johnson sirleaf
did talk about some things in common
they talked about a relentless focus on
appearance and needing to deal with that
and
adopting strategies to deal with
people's interest in what they were
wearing
they talked about a focus on family
structures
they talked even as leaders about being
underestimated in rooms feeling that
they constantly had to prove themselves
they talked about walking on a very
narrow tightrope of showing enough
strength
to be seen to be you know tough enough
to lead
but having enough warmth and empathy
that people wouldn't find them
unlikable and have an adverse reaction
against them
so one thing that really stood out for
me in putting the book together
is how universal the experiences of
sexism are
now that doesn't mean that they're at
the same degree of
sting and amplitude in every place
obviously that differs and differs
profoundly
but the manifestations are more common
than you would initially think
yeah i was interested i mean in how much
you think they do vary between countries
because theresa may in your
conversations she quite often sort of
says actually i don't think
i was being discriminated against as a
woman she sort of plays it down you
obviously famously found yourself on the
end of a great deal of sexism and
australian policy i mean is australian
politics
more sexist than british politics do you
think
i don't think more sexist no i think
maybe our political culture is more
rough and tumble than yours even though
we got the institutions of our politics
from you of course
and i'm prepared to make that judgment
call based on the reactions that i've
seen from
british politicians who have come and
visited the australian parliament
and watched our question time and walked
away shaking their heads going oh my
heavens what on earth was that
so we we play it tough and at none of
these
uh niceties of prime minister's question
times
in australia the prime minister goes to
question time every day
and takes what comes and often what
comes is pretty hard-hitting
so i think maybe our sexism is more
out there in our culture but i don't
think that there's a fundamental
difference
no and this business of rough and tumble
being a kind of
part of politics i mean that's itself
almost a kind of
gendered or traditionally gendered way
of seeing things
as they're sort of scrapping as being a
male thing do you think
there is something that is actually it's
set up
most political systems in a quite male
way or is that to say it's just that
women need to play the game
that way look i think a mix of all of
those things
i mean i am not a believer that men and
women's brains are somehow inherently
different
and we unpack a fair bit of that in the
book and we end up concluding
that a lot of the men are from mars
women are from venus sort of stuff
is neurosexism not neuroscience
but we do recognize that men and women
have been socialized differently
and that institutions of long-standing
and long
history like parliaments have grown
their conventions
in times when this was a male game when
women
weren't there having said all of that
i as a politician thought it was very
important to show
that a woman could stand in as
adversarial a place
as our question time and dominate it you
know bend it to your will
and i didn't do that every day i was
prime minister but i did it some days
and i think that's the best almost any
prime minister could say for themselves
in terms of their track record in
question time so
i don't think you can somehow bake the
sexism
in and say women can never thrive in
adversarial institutions
but i also recognise that because of
socialisation because women tend to be
you know more conflict adverse more
prepared to
negotiate and find solutions that that
rough and tumble to use the terminology
that we started with
does alienate a lot of women and that
they would like to see
politics done differently and i look at
jacinda ardern and it's interesting to
see that
she is the third woman to lead her
country
is trying to find a way to do politics
differently with kindness very much
foregrounded i mean it's a bit of a
chicken and egg question
but do you think you need to try and
change the institutions and the styles
of politics in order to accommodate
if you like a socialization that's going
to take longer to go away or that
it's simply a question that women when
they get out front in politics
need to learn to play the game that way
as it is
i mean you clearly did it that way yes i
did and maybe i'm the transition model
and the women of the future
uh will be much more trying to change
the rules of the system
maybe we're in that kind of progression
of it being a male institution of women
who
came in like me and largely accepted the
rules of the institution then seeking to
thrive within it
and then a generation of women who'll
try and completely knock the rules of
the game around maybe that's the
evolution we're in
i think that there will always be
some conflict baked into politics
because at the end of the day
politics is about a clash of values a
clash of policies and
people who've got strong beliefs in what
their nation should do next what the
world should do next
will always want to come in and have the
argument but on the styles of the
argument
i think that there's more reasons than
gender and diversity to be looking now
at the institutions of politics it's
clear that in
western democracies around the world
people are increasingly
alienated frustrated with politics as
it's currently played so
i think that there's an agenda here
about democratic renewal
as well as one around better gender
diversity and better diversity generally
yeah what was your experience i mean one
of the things that interested me in the
books you say
if i had my time again i'd do it
slightly differently
why was that why do you feel you'd make
gender a bigger thing earlier on
yeah hindsight's a wonderful thing
unfortunately when i
started being prime minister i didn't
get a crystal ball
issued to me uh with many of the other
things that came with being prime
minister i would have liked one
but i assumed when i first became prime
minister that
it was just so obvious that i was the
first woman to do the job i didn't need
to wander around saying to people
do you realize i'm the first woman to do
the job i mean all of the headlines you
know
all of it was about being the first
woman to do the job
and then i thought over time
that we'll become less intriguing to
people
it will become less of the way in which
my prime ministership is seen
and people will go back to evaluating me
in the normal way that we evaluate
politicians in australia which is never
particularly kindly but it's our
structures and we're all used to them
what i actually found was the longer i
was prime minister the more harder
arguments the government had to have
and we particularly had a ferocious
argument about creating an economy-wide
emissions trading scheme to
deal with carbon that the gendered
insult
gendered characterizations of my
leadership became
more and more the order of the day so
then i did regret
that i hadn't called out earlier
the first manifestations of sexism that
i hadn't assumed that they would
basically exit the scene that instead i
tackled it
head-on earlier on so that it didn't get
as bad as it got later on
and when you were sort of scrapping at
the dispatch box
did you feel obviously having been
socialized in the way you've been
socialized
that you were sort of putting on a
persona that you'd sort of put on your
armor before you'd
deliver a speech or stand at pmq's
oh very much so but i don't necessarily
think
that's a gendered experience in terms of
question time you know i mean no no one
in real life
conducts themselves the way that
politicians conduct themselves at
question time whether it's your um
you know prime minister's question time
or our version of it
i mean it's a very stereotyped
mannered way of behaving and so i think
everybody
pulls on a bit of a role and a bit of
armour to go into that
and i don't really think in terms of
gender that you know the biggest
set of issues that we've got to overcome
are about the dynamics of question time
i actually think there's two far broader
fields that we need to look at
one is structural which is because
politics has been built up around the
pattern of men's lives and men
men at the time that it was routine for
men in politics to have a non-working
spouse
that political structures have not
easily adapted
to the rhythm of women's lives and the
balance of work and family life
and second we've all got uh sexist
stereotypes whispering in the back of
our brains
uh the global research shows this very
very clearly
and until we name them analyze them
and get them out of all of our heads
then we are at risk
of putting extra burdens on the
shoulders of women leaders and so we
need to work our throat
way through that and the book is a
contribution to
showing what those stereotypes are and
how we need to defeat them
i mean actually that does raise a
question i wondered about
how much do you think that what you're
talking about in this book as it were
scales in the sense that the women
you're talking about
are all exceptional they're occupying
absolutely you know one percent of one
percent jobs at the top of
nations or institutions how much the
lessons that you draw from them
apply and as it were trickled down to
women overall and throughout you know
throughout the world who are in less
less exceptional women in less
exceptional circumstances
i think women are only viewed as
exceptional when you take a snapshot of
one section of their lives you know at
the top of their game
but what we do in the book is we look at
early influences
and each woman's pathway to power
and if you look at that then there are
many years many decades in which
these women would not have been seen to
be exceptional and i
put myself in that very profoundly you
know i'm a
daughter from a migrant family we
migrated from the
uk to australia i went to the local
government schools
there was nothing exceptional about me
or exceptional about
us in my early days and that was true of
much of my life so because we
take the story all of the way through
i think that there are many moments in
these women's journeys
that women in other walks of life women
who are at much earlier stages of their
career will
say yes that's exactly what happened to
me or that's exactly how i feel about it
and then even at the height of their
powers
there are moments that these women share
that i think will resonate
you know ellen johnson sirleaf talks
about
as president going to meetings with
presidents across africa and still
feeling differential attention and still
feeling like she wasn't fully accepted
in that room
and i think that there will be you know
women who are in the
first days of their career walking into
the first work rooms they'll ever walk
into
who will go yep i know exactly what that
feels like
yeah i mean one of the issues that
in terms of increasing representation of
women all over you know when you've got
a
fantastic number of statistics about the
under-representation of women in
boardrooms in parliament and
all around the world is this question of
how much
is affirmative action something that's
necessary because
you know lots of people feel it's kind
of cleft stick because if you have
quotas or something like that people go
oh she only got the job because she's
women
and if you don't arguably nothing
changes
how do you square that what do you feel
about
affirmative action and pushing them
forward by fiat if you like
i am of the generation that fought for
an affirmative action rule in the
australian labor party we did that
in the 1990s and there's
just no doubt that it's been effective
and that we are a better and stronger
political party because of it
in terms of the effectiveness if you go
back to the days we adopted our
affirmative action rule
and you looked at the national
parliament then both the labour party
and the conservative side of politics
were around about
13 14 women in their parliamentary teams
so
dreadful all these years later the labor
party is
pretty close to half half and the
conservative side of politics that said
no they would not do a target or a quota
they would rely on networking and
training and those sorts of things
have clawed their way up to about a
quarter of their team being women
so the labor party's affirmative action
rule worked
and when people say well you know this
means
it's counted to merit or anything like
that
i think they're incredibly flawed
arguments if you believe as i do that
merit is equally distributed between the
sexes
and you see any team whether that's a
parliamentary team a corporate board a
judicial bench or anything else
that isn't around half men half women
then there's got to be something
that is stopping women of merit coming
through and why wouldn't you want those
women of merit there as well
so ultimately i think fixing gender
diversity and diversity more broadly
enriches and strengthens teams it does
not detract from the merit principle
do you feel there's a point at which
obviously that's a transitional thing
and you go
okay at this stage we've got a system
where roughly it's 50 50.
you know the bars to entry have been
broken down right now we remove
quotas i think it just gets to a stage
and
this has increasingly been the
experience within the labor party it
just gets to a stage where
it's kind of not that relevant anymore
you know when we first had affirmative
action
people would have been out with their
sheets oh were we
okay with the affirmative action rule
have we got this right or is there a
problem
now people get around with the
pre-selections and then
you know look back and go yeah of course
it's all right um
so yes it gets to a stage where it's so
baked in that you don't have to
specifically
focus on it any longer i was very
interested to read how you describe your
own
political making and you know you
started out
student unions and you describe
and it's an old story about you know
feminism being split
and you know there was a sort of
separatist women separatist movements
and you were you were on the other side
on the integration side now we've got
another split in feminism between
women who argue that there's a conflict
between the rights of nato women and
trans women
where do you stand on that issue we talk
in the book about
how it would be truly wonderful if when
we looked at
the councils of the world whether that
was a meeting of the un
or the g20 or the g7 or any of those
structures that you could look at who
is leading and see the full range and
full diversity
of humankind and everybody was
represented
that's not where we are now and so we've
done this analysis
around gender but of course it's not the
only form of discrimination and i hope
that
you know there are many many many
contributions to
uh bringing out all of the other forms
of discrimination that need to be
tackled
so that politics and leadership
generally can draw on everybody's
talents and abilities and not
artificially exclude people
in terms of the threads of feminism that
we talk about
in the book i mean my university career
i started at university in the late
1970s and was there in the 1980s
and there was a very lively debate
in feminist circles on campus then
between
being within the structures and changing
them from within
as opposed to having women's only spaces
and you know women who wanted to
completely
change structures to move away from any
pyramid-style power structures to more
collective structures
i was on one side of that and i guess my
life's work has been on one side of that
but i think
we're a measurable measure immeasurably
strengthened by the fact that there's a
diversity of view
and different people employ different
strategies for change
just to reiterate the initial question
there is a good faith argument
going on between people who are on a
sort of progressive side of things
some people argue that the rights of
trans women
through self-identification so on are in
conflict
with the rights of nato women and their
ability to describe themselves as a
political class
i'm wondering where you stand on that
issue i actually think it's flawed
i actually think it's flawed to set this
up as a
choice a or choice be i think there's uh
we're all still thinking it through
working through there's plenty of
dialogue to be had and it should be
very inclusive and respectful dialogue
fair enough
now i'm someone who takes a special
interest in rhetoric so i can't not ask
you about the misogyny speech and you'll
probably
roll your eyes but that speech
seemed really crafted and structured
and i've read you say somewhere you know
what it kind of just came out
did you know that you were going to
deliver this tub thumper
i i didn't even know i was going to
deliver a speech so
no absolutely not i uh walked into
what should have been question time one
of these uh question times we've been
talking about so
much and i knew that the theme of the
day
would be sexism because there was a
political scandal running about the
speaker of the house of representatives
who had
been unveiled as having sent some very
crude and sexist text messages and
obviously
you know it is the government that
supports the speaker and so
the government which i led had put this
man into the speaker's office
though we could not have known about the
text messages at the time we did that
so i expected that the theme of question
time
would be around sexism and hypocrisy
trying to charge the government and me
in particular
as hypocritical because of the man we'd
supported to be speaker
so i went in prepared for that and
the preparation was to take in some key
quotes of
the leader of the opposition tony abbott
that were sexist and i was intending in
answering questions to flourish these
quotes around
but as it happened when we got in there
instead of having question time the
leader of the opposition
moved a motion to censure the government
and so we went straight into that debate
and so the speech that's come to be
known as the misogyny speech is the
speech i gave in reply
to his speech moving that motion and so
i wrote down some
notes to give me a sense of the
structure of the speech and then
gave it well it's kind of extraordinary
there's so much anaphora in it i mean
it's really
it's quite a thing to improvise when you
sat down you i mean did you sort of
think
i've reduced tony abbott to a smoldering
ruin because you're kind of dead
uh no i mean i knew
that it was a speech that had landed
with considerable force
in the house of representatives i mean
you spend enough time i've spent
spend enough years by then in parliament
to know when
a speech has you know really hit the
other side hard
as opposed to one that's just run of the
mill so i knew it it hit
home but i didn't have any
anticipation about it beyond
how it had landed in the chamber so i
knew that the people in the chamber had
felt the force of it i expected that the
journalists would
write it up some of them you know saying
it was a good speech some of them saying
it was a bad speech you know such is the
nature of uh political reporting but i
didn't expect it to go any further than
that
right now i know we aren't supposed to
be talking about
current day politics but i have to ask
because he's about to be made a trade
adviser
um do you think the aforementioned
smuldering ruin will have anything to
contribute to
britain's trade deals with europe
you won't be surprised that i'm leaving
all of that to the government and the
people of the uk to sort out it's for
you to work out who you want to be your
trade advisor not for me to do it
and anything that i've needed to say
about
tony abbott i said when i was in
politics and most particularly in the
speech that we've just been talking
about so
i don't need to add that's very
diplomatic
get out of the way your relationship
with ngozi
what did you find the parts of which
your perspectives differed
we worked through lots of things
i mean mostly we were in agreement from
the early days we were in
agreement about the fundamental nature
of the book about the research and the
women's lives
we then had to work through the
structuring of it and we worked through
a variety of
ways about best structuring the book and
then as we wrestled the content
really i would say the main discussion
between us was about
handling issues around race
and intersectionality what it meant for
ngozi to have intersected in the
political world as a black woman what it
meant
for ellen and for joyce and
how we should write about that i mean
so i wouldn't i wouldn't put that i
should just be clear i wouldn't put that
in the sense that we had
different views but ngozi had the far
more
sophisticated lived experience view so i
learned from her as we wrote yeah now
you do
talk in the book about a divide
between if you like intellectual or kind
of
head feminism and a sort of more
spiritual or
personal emotional one you talk you talk
about being kind of
uncomfortable with that divide and
feeling it you know sometimes you're
on the wrong side of it how do you kind
of reconcile it do you think
yeah i do talk in the prologue both
ngozi and i give our
histories in some ways and the
perspectives that we've brought to the
book
and i do recount in that my journey in
student politics
awakening to these debates about
feminism how that all fueled my
political activism
and how i came out of that very much as
a
can do style of politician
that i took with me from those early
experiences
drive to get things done and including
getting things done on women's equality
and so i was always someone who was
motivated to make a difference on
women's equality but
it was like having a checklist yes got
that done
okay got the next thing done right got
the next thing done
rather than feeling some of the more
emotional
ties that i think there can be
when women come together around a cause
and celebrate each other's
achievements and when i look back on
that i don't know whether
the structures of politics mean you kind
of flatten the emotion down and just put
your head down and get it done
or whether it's simply a time thing you
don't have the
luxury of celebrating achievements or
just
hanging together and i've got more time
to do that now than i had when i was
in active politics but i do feel a more
emotional
strain around my feminism now than i did
when i was
in the seaters deputy prime minister or
prime minister or
any of the other political seats that i
held before that that was a lovely
detail i think when one of your
colleagues loses their seat
and you shed a tear at the top of the
case you're going soft get out
yes that's right it was actually a happy
occasion so it was when a great friend
of mine a woman who'd worked
in my office with me post my time as
prime minister
gave her first speech as an incoming
senator and i went to
watch it be given and did feel emotional
and was chided
by a former colleague of mine who's
still in parliament as
going soft yeah now that business of
which is you know we could say maybe
part of of the way
women are socialized you know we're not
going to be essentialists but
of being more emotionally labeled being
more sociable of being more
kind of empathetic and responsive and
all those things
i mean do you think that means that the
way that women do rhetoric
is different that the way women give
speeches in politics
you know is different in some ways
yes but i think that's not
necessarily because women
choose to do it differently if women had
every choice
and didn't have the sort of stretches
that come with socialization
i don't know whether it would be so
different
but i think it's different now because
we see very clearly from the research
and the lived experience of these women
that women who gave speeches
in a very male style women who
were directive commanding
clearly ambitious women who spoke
like that would generate a very adverse
reaction
and so i think women
learn early on to give their
political contributions or public
contributions in a different style
one that foregrounds the team one that
foregrounds
why things are being done in the
interests of others
we often hear women describe themselves
as
lucky you know i've got to this position
because i've been lucky
not because i've been good at it you
know all of those rhetorical devices
tend to come into play
because women are picking their way on
this narrow path
between being seen as strong enough to
lead but still
warm enough to be likable yeah mrs
thatcher famously took
speech lessons to lower her voice do you
think that's
that's something that still would apply
or have we moved a bit
since then because obviously she wanted
to be sound a bit more commanding
yeah i think we've probably moved a bit
but not as much as we should have and
i'm you know sure that when
tv studios are thinking about
the next presenters you know the the
people who are going to bring you the
nightly news
or the allocation of stories between
what gets presented by the male anchor
and the female anchor
i'm sure that there's still some of this
in the system where people think that
male voices are more commanding
there's a lot of talk about glass
ceilings i hadn't come across the phrase
glass cliff until this book
was a glass cliff yeah we do end up
saying uh there's a hell of a lot of
glass
so the glass ceiling uh people would be
familiar with certainly hillary clinton
talked about bumping her head on one of
those high hard glass ceilings
the glass cliff is uh trackable
phenomenon
that women are more likely to be offered
leadership roles when things are going
badly this is particularly
known from the corporate world that if a
business is going well
then you know you might as well get a
ceo who's a fair bit like the current
ceo and the current ceo is a man
if a business is going badly then
corporate boards say let's shake things
up and that's when they will
perhaps appoint their first woman and
this all came to the fore
because of an article in the uk
that was published which said that
women ceos are correlated with falling
share prices
but when researchers looked at that it
was the other way round
falling share prices was correlated with
the appointment of female ceos
so that that is the glass cliff then we
also talk about the glass labyrinth
so yes much glass and we
use that to try and describe this
pathway
journey that we talked about earlier
that we aren't
in this book simply trying to talk about
what happens
when you're a woman who's trying to move
from being deputy ceo to ceo
or deputy political leader to political
leader
we're trying to identify every point in
a woman's journey where she was treated
differently and lesser well with all
that glass it's been smashing to talk to
you
thank you very much indeed for your time
[Music]
you